hey Amy can we have a second no I'm kind
of oh yeah well
[ __ ] yourself all right all right I
don't believe in loopholes what
loopholes are the best remember that
time when Pancake Palace had that all
you can eat deal but they didn't set a
time limit I ate pancakes for a week for
3.99 all I had to do was sleep there and
never shower what thanks for the invite
friend I will not be using a loop over
Alta as always I'll be using the main
hole or no hole I choose no holes he
just said hole way too much sir and
that's coming from Charles yes that's
concerning we're on our way right now to
talk to a lead that knows where
Garibaldi's Hideout is you're
quarantined you can't go outside spewing
mumps like a couple of month fountains
not like this weekend
[Music]
stop you can't leave at all good luck
trying to stop us you'll never catch us
baby is Usain Bolt sir you wanted to see
me yes I have an assignment for you I'm
afraid it's not a pleasant one oh my God
just tell me it's not yes it's Hitchcock
related
protective Hitchcock is set to testify
in court this afternoon it's an
important case and I'd rather not get
another call from the D.A saying he
showed up quote covered in condiments
unquested so you want me to keep
Hitchcock from spilling on himself for
the rest of the day we both know that's
impossible I'm counting on I won't do it
there's nobody else I trust what you're
asking is insane I'm not asking it's a
suicide mission prepare for death you've
lost your mind this is a direct order
detective get in line hey you guys
startled Hitchcock he spilled two full
jars of spaghetti sauce on himself
thanks a lot drum roll please
foreign
any reasonable person would default to
lento well it's terrible and you ruined
a fun thing but I would still like to
introduce you to Mr Gordon what
Mr Gordon Lunt
Gordon you want to come in here oh I'm
so sorry I was just deciding whether I
should just go home the tone antenna of
your introduction make me worry that
this is a fun office which I would not
enjoy
hello I'm captain Raymond hold and I can
assure you this is not a fun office
thank goodness in that case my interest
is renewed here is my resume oh I'm
feeling this are you guys feeling this
Gordon why don't you tell Captain Holt a
little bit about yourself where to begin
I'm 174 centimeters tall I can type 103
words per minute with an error rate of
1.6 percent and I recently moved here
from Philadelphia which is the sixth
most populous U.S city I understand the
city of Philadelphia is coterminous with
Philadelphia County making it the eighth
largest metropolitan statistical area
yeah Philly's cool isn't it fun just
telling each other facts yes well I
think I have all the information I need
thank you for coming in Mr my pleasure
so looks like operation nasty is a
full-on success huh you mean operation
nasty sex a lot depends didn't you see
him flirting with me no I most
definitely did not and you're a blind
man and it proved to boot did you see
his tie a single Windsor the easiest
knot to undo why bother wearing any
clothes at home I think you badly
misread that interaction please he did
everything but lick his lips and purr
hey everyone so
to be D
Fun Zone we live by one rule when it's
your birthday you are always cool
parents and kids are all the same watch
as I do a dance
to your name
Derek
Eric
let's catch those guys who can give hold
some good news I want to cheer him up
well how do you even know he's in a bad
mood I mean it's impossible to read that
guy this is the most incompetent
worthless report I have ever written
and get your act together or so help me
God you won't live to see retirement
it's like what's that guy thinking you
know
I can read him and if anyone can figure
out what's bothering him it's me he and
I are exactly the same
except that I'm younger Cuban female
single and straight Kevin Holt's not gay
come on it's gay seriously man just
retire
for you
and you and you what are these these
madam are STDs
what are you talking about Buddy STDs
save the dates for Viviana my wedding ah
yes hey just out of curiosity how many
people have you given STDs to Lots like
a hundred
what's going on uh oh okay I get it STD
has another meaning you're gross no one
else is gonna think that everyone is
going to think that but it's sweet that
your mind didn't go there thank you it
is kind of sweet will your first dance
be to you give me fever will you be
serving crabs at the reception do you
have herpes guys
right and we're sorry we love you buddy
warts and all sorry I made a rash
decision I was itching to say it okay
I'm done
I have an STD
so just RSVP or yeah the numbers right
on there he's leaving our plan worked we
saved our own honeymoon and fun bonus we
cheered up halt yes okay it's time to
celebrate you know what that means this
bee needs a c in her a oh my God this
babe needs a coconut in her arms Oh I
thought you were saying this music oh my
God that was my reaction all right I'll
go get us a couple of coconuts Hank
bring me
a charbonne
damn sure you took that Chardonnay to
the house how you feeling let me take
stock my equilibrium is Askew my vision
is partially impaired and I'm clearly
slurring my words to put a fine point on
it your boy's turned well well well
there's only a minute left and you are
six bucks down I don't think you guys
are gonna make it hang another job this
one's hot it was sitting on the radiator
she's never gonna make it yes he will
just don't breathe let the liquid into
your lungs
five four three two Closing Time cops
with
[Applause]
yeah all right fine
the bar is yours but
we're keeping this come on before we all
go home and pass out I want to say how
sorry I am that I deserted you earlier I
want you to know that I care about you
all so very much each and every one of
you Boyle Santiago Diaz Hitchcock skull
uh need your help with the case three
antique coins were stolen from my
Classics Department of Colombia so why
not ask Captain hold for help on the
case wait are you guys getting a divorce
I can handle it this doesn't bring up
any weird issues for me no it's nothing
like that Raymond's a brilliant
detective it's just when a case involves
me he can get a little over emotional
you remember the safe house oh yeah he
went crazy but I also remember you and
me becoming best friends and watching
every Nick Cage movie ever made can you
still quote them all no I purged myself
of that nonsense I bet it's still in
there there's a chance it's in the
chance of zero I'd put money that maybe
it's there you're losing your money okay
so you still want to pretend you had
nothing to do with this I didn't and she
didn't either Trudy Judy's not a carthy
Judy Judy's an angel she's put herself
through nursing school and nurses are
the best of our society name one bad
nurse nurse ratchet Kathy Bates and
misery Nurse Jackie had a pill problem
okay damn got a lot of real good
examples off the top of your head you
believe me right Jake I mean the fact
pattern's not great but Trudy did seem
very nice when I met her you're trying
to get your freak on with my sister what
no I see you looking at Trudy Judy's
booty I am not looking at true to Judy's
booty oh you don't think she's a cutie
don't be snooty She's a Beauty but I'm
on duty and you're married oh yeah but
that doesn't rhyme